when it comes to viewer requests for
specific videos I currently can't think
of one I've received more than an
analyzed review of under the skin I had
the privilege of seeing this film twice
in theaters this year I couldn't help
but recall Roger Ebert speaking about
the first time he saw a 2001 a Space
Odyssey he felt like he had stumbled
upon something visually unique and
special a film that deserved to be
examined closely so as I've done in the
past with films like enemy or only God
forgives let's go in depth with under
the skin and discuss the meaning of the
film there's a lot of hidden gems in
this one as I often remind you this is
only my interpretation of the movie
others may have their own this is just
how I see it as I usually do I will
discuss the events of the film and then
sum up my thoughts on what was actually
taking place the film opens with odd
spherical shapes floating through a vast
empty space we here who I will simply
refer to as Scarlett from now on
enunciated learning how to speak like a
human eventually we see these circular
shapes form an eyeball let's just get
this out of the way first Scarlett is an
alien sent to earth on a mission a
mission for what we'll get to that soon
next we see motorcycle man traversing
the streets at night he seems to be on a
mission of some kind he stops his
motorcycle and disappears into the
darkness after a moment he returns
carrying the limp body of a woman
we abruptly cut to Scarlett standing
over this woman naked she removes the
woman's clothes and puts them on herself
suddenly the woman is now looking
directly at Scarlett a tear falls down
her cheek
Scarlett examines an ant that was
crawling on the woman her first contact
with a creature from Earth a spaceship
or possibly a few spaceships depart from
the top of a skyscraper and Scarlett
descends the stairs to the bottom the
seemingly superior motorcycle man had
a man waiting for her and she drives off
she enters a mall and observes human
behavior she quickly learns mankind's
superficial view of beauty and tries to
emulate it by putting on makeup
soon she is driving again she appears to
be hunting hunting from men she tries to
seduce many passers-by and interestingly
some of these scenes were done without
the knowledge of the men who were filmed
with hidden cameras and later signed
agreements to be in the movie eventually
she is able to lure one of them to an
apartment building where they enter a
black void take note of the music
playing during this scene not only is it
a fantastic soundtrack but it is a theme
that occurs whenever Scarlett is luring
men in with her beauty whenever she is
the hunter as she removes her clothes
the helpless man follows sinking further
and further into some kind of liquid
eventually he is completely consumed
next we have what is possibly the most
disturbing scene in the whole movie
Scarlett observes some people swimming
in the ocean she briefly attempts to
lure one of them into her web before he
runs off to save a woman who has
accidentally floated out too far into
sea attempting to rescue her drowning
dog when this family eventually drowns
the rescuer returns to the shore there
the emotionless Scarlett bashes him over
the head with a rock and drags him away
leaving the family's baby behind notice
that her hunter theme returns during
this scene again later motorcycle man
appears cleaning up the scene at the
beach however he leaves the helpless
baby behind
Scarlett continues her hunt and ends up
at a nearby Club where she successfully
lures another man back to the black void
except this time when the man sinks into
the pool of liquid we see underneath
there he witnesses Scarlett's previous
victim being eaten away by the liquid
until he's nothing but a lifeless wisp
of a man his meaty parts are then
processed along some kind of conveyor
belt disappearing down a red shaft in
the next scene Scarlett is given a rose
from a flower vendor she notices there
was blood on the thorns and she sees the
vendor
covering up a hand bandage likely from
his constant handling of the thorns
after sending yet another man to be
processed we see Scarlett standing in a
dark room being closely examined by
motorcycle man he stares at her
intensely looking deep into her eyes
don't worry I'll get to this stuff soon
next Scarlett is walking through a
crowded Street and slips falling to the
ground she notices a large group of
people offering to help her up
and appears taken aback by this then we
get a series of shots showcasing people
doing everyday things meaningless tasks
that only seem significant to someone
truly observing humanity her next
encounter will be her most important one
she picks up a man whose face is very
deformed and she attempts to make small
talk with him like she always does with
these men she views his prey
she learns that he's never been with a
woman and has no friends when she lures
him back to the void she begins to
remove her clothes and leads the man
forward until he's consumed by the
liquid like everyone else she exits the
room and stops abruptly in front of a
mirror she gazes at her reflection and
seems to have a sudden epiphany she then
notices a fly trapped in the glass pane
of the door it's then that she makes the
decision that changes the rest of her
life she begins to feel she lets the
deformed man escape and he flees into
the grass motorcycle man seems to be
aware of everything she does because he
is suddenly on the move now we see
Scarlett in a very different way she
appears afraid for the first time
unsure she doesn't understand what's
happening to her motorcycle man quickly
tracks down the deformed man and locks
him in a trunk driving away presumably
to kill him or get rid of him or
something like that
soon Scarlett ditches her van and runs
to a nearby town as motorcycle man
tracks her every move in this town
Scarlett tries very unsuccessfully to
eat a piece of cake she spits the cake
out and leaves the restaurant she
aimlessly wanders onto a bus her
expression reveals she is terribly
confused by what is happening to her a
kind passenger on this bus takes pity on
her and in
bites her back to his place and offers
her shelter for the night this gives her
even more opportunities to observe human
behavior as she watches a comedy show
and even starts tapping her finger to
some music when she is left alone in the
guest room later that night she gazes at
her naked body in the mirror it's clear
that she becomes taken with her
appearance she discovers her physical
beauty then we see multiple motorcycle
men searching for the rogue scarlet as
she goes about another day of discovery
with this man hiking through the woods
and seeing the sights of the land it's
at the end of this day where she
attempts to make love to this man even
though she doesn't really know what that
entails which is made painfully clear
when he tries to penetrate her and she
lunges upward bringing the nearby lamp
to her crotch examining whatever is
going on down there she flees into the
woods terrified where she encounters a
logger who warns her to watch her step
she next comes upon a hikers retreat a
small building made to shelter hikers
who are trapped in a storm horrified she
falls asleep there when she is awakened
by the logger attempting to rape her she
escapes into the woods with him
following closely behind as he comes
upon her Scarlett's hunting theme music
is heard again however this time she is
the prey as they struggle on the ground
the man suddenly backs away in terror
when he sees a large portion of scarlet
skin tear away
scarlet sits up and begins to remove her
skin revealing her true alien form soon
the logger returns dousing her with fuel
and lighting her on fire she falls to
the ground in a burning heap dead
leaving motorcycle man still searching
for her now for some more discerning
audience members this movie was fairly
straightforward others were perplexed
from start to finish which I can
completely understand when the movie
begins we are witnessing Scarlett take
the place of an alien who allowed human
emotion to creep into her nature as
witnessed by a tear falling down her
Scarlet's encounter with the aunt was
her first encounter with something from
Earth she witnesses mankind's
superficial view of beauty and attempts
to copy it luring men to be processed by
some sort of alien liquid as a machine
distributes their meaty parts somewhere
this is her mission and she must act out
her prime directive without ever letting
humanity infect her this is what the
motorcycle man was doing when he closely
examined her he was seeing it the same
fate that befell the previous alien
woman was happening to her as well soon
Scarlett begins to take note of the more
incidental things people do and
witnesses kindness when people help her
up she witnesses the man who was selling
roses even though the thorns were
actually pricking at him all of these
things have a major effect on her but
it's not until she begins to feel pity
for the deformed man then witnesses the
trapped fly thinks of that deformed man
and lets him escape that her life gets
flipped completely upside down she
begins to try even more human things
like eating cake listening to music and
even having sex none of them work out
because she simply isn't human when she
is nearly raped by the logger we see
again mankind's superficial view of
beauty prevalent he is sexually aroused
by her appearance and wants to take
advantage of her
but as soon as he sees her for who she
really is
her true beauty under the skin his first
reaction is to kill her for me this was
a powerful study on the way we perceived
Beauty we so often view it as a physical
thing and we ignore what a person really
is focusing only on the outside
often when we finally do discover a
person for who they are
we are turned off somehow and want
nothing to do with this person anymore
and some people are caught at a
crossroads like Scarlett's character I'm
sure of who they are what their purpose
in life is afraid to break free from the
norm and challenge authority under the
skin has many important messages like
this hidden throughout
and I hope this video helps shed some
light on some of them it's a film that I
can see being examined for years to come
and one that I think deserves to be of
course this isn't to say that all of
humankind has a superficial view of
beauty it's just that a large majority
of us kind of do thanks so much as
always guys for watching my analyze
reviews I will do my best to do even
more of them in the future
they take some time and I appreciate
your patience but I'm happy to do ones
that you guys would like me to do thanks
so much guys and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
steppen eyes